SCP-682, the indestructible reptile, versus
SCP-1237, the epsilon wave, who would win?
In an attempt to terminate SCP-682, the Foundation
gave us the answer.
SCP-1237 is a brain pattern occurring in deep
REM sleep that allows an individual's dreams
to shape and affect reality when they wake.
One specimen affected by SCP-1237 was permitted
to observe SCP-682 and was instructed to dream
that SCP-682 was a small house cat with no
anomalous abilities, and that the Foundation
had successfully terminated it.
Seven seconds into their sleep, the subject
seized violently and died less than a minute
later, alongside 13 other observing security
personnel.
Their bodies were covered with scratches and
bites, as well as symptoms of toxoplasmosis
and bubonic plague.
Inside SCP-682’s chamber was a small house
cat, licking blood from its coat of fur.
It regenerated into SCP-682 only a few hours
later.
Looks like in this matchup, the lizard, not
the cat, got the foundation’s tongue, as
expected.